[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est passée j'ai commencé à peindre
des robots sur des cailloux avec mon
fils cela m'a donné confiance en ma
capacité de créer des univers et surtout
j'ai écouté un désir que je refoulais
depuis des années celui de dessiner j'ai
entrepris l'écriture d'une histoire
voire au beau voyage dans le temps ce
qui l'amène à faire des bêtises imprévu
non intentionnelle dans cette histoire
il ya aussi beaucoup de robots qui ont
une nouvelle capacité c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ne sont ni maître ni en métaux ni
en plastique
ils sont dans une matière imaginaire qui
me permette qui me permet de faire des
choses magiques
imaginez que vous soyez porté par un
exosquelette un exo robot et qui vous
permette d'aller sur le mont blanc
beaucoup plus facilement imaginer que
sur votre montre s'être se cache un
petit robot qui peut tout à coup flotter
quand on écrit une histoire on est amené
à se projeter dans la peau des
personnages à faire appel à nos émotions
nouvelles notre vécu par exemple combien
d'entre vous ici ont déjà avec une
situation avec une un bateau pris par
les houles et drôle d'émotion qui se
font ressentir dans le corps l'appel au
secours de vos amis de vos proches
donc quand on est écrivain quand on est
dessinateur ont fait appel à notre
empathie pour comprendre chaque
personnage
et donc forcément ni robots donc je dois
admettre qu'ils écrire une histoire avec
des robots ça a transformé ma vision de
la robotique
pourquoi j'ai commencé à attribuer des
droits
naturellement au fil de l'eau des droits
à pouvoir prendre la parole ça me
paraissait logique naturelle
le robot qui puisse s'exprimer qu'ils
puissent partager ses connaissances de
manière circulaire le droit au silence
le droit à l'oubli droit ne pas oublier
le droit à une transmettre une
information quand c'est nécessaire
dans certaines situations le droit de
pouvoir observer le monde au service de
tous d'avoir une certaine mobilité et
c'est et comment le faire
c'est compliqué est ce qu'un robot a le
droit de traverser une frontière un
robot quelque part pourrait avoir le
droit de vivre l'instant présent être à
ce moment là le seul à pouvoir
visualiser quelque chose évidemment il y
avait la question du consentement
on aimerait bien que les robots soit
complètement loyaux mais le problème
c'est que nous avons parfois les
problèmes de morale et c'est juste ça
fait du sens que le robot puisse
questionner puisse être dans le pourquoi
pourquoi veux tu faire ça quel est ton
désir derrière par exemple dans mon
histoire il ya des cambriolages
évidemment je ne fais pas participé mon
robot
en fait mon histoire est profondément
imprégné de mes valeurs je me rends
compte au fur et à mesure de l'écriture
que j'ai envie j'ai un désir que les
robots puissent être gouvernés par des
fondations d'utilité publique pour
qu'ils puissent passer d'une fondation
et une autre quand ça fait du sens ou
qu'ils puissent avoir de lait coûte
inversement les méchants individus
comment les noms de la science fiction
sont des propriétaires de robots qui
cherche à tout prix à les récupérer
quitte à faire du tort à d'autres
personnes la science fiction et la
robotique
c'est une histoire d'amour qui date de
très longtemps je viens du golem il ya
500 ans
il ya les fabuleuses histoires avec
isaac asimov et ça fait longtemps que
les scientifiques utilisent la science
fiction pour comprendre le futur donc
rien de nouveau et la thématique des
droits et des robots rien de nouveau
par contre les technologies ont évolué
on pourrait penser que la recherche qui
a été démarrée sur les robots sociaux
est capable d'embrasser les changements
actuels et en fait ce n'est pas le cas
récemment une experte disait à la radio
il ne faut pas que les robots il est
droit j'écoute ça je me dis mais c'est
étrange
ça correspond pas au droit naturel que
j'ai envie d'attribuer au robot est-ce
que j'ai une dissonance cognitive est ce
que je suis dans le tort et je me rends
compte qu'en fait derrière cette posture
de négation se cachent beaucoup plus de
choses et que c'est beaucoup plus riches
en fait les experts aujourd'hui essaient
de rendre naturel la conversation entre
humains et la machine ils en sont au
point qu'ils ont réussi à le mettre en
place des algorithmes pour développer de
l'empathie d'à part du robot
en sorte que le robot puisse donner du
sens même s'il n'a pas encore
aujourd'hui un sens commun un sens
complet qu'ils puissent comprendre dans
certains contextes votre situation
les experts aussi notre mission faire en
sorte que les robots ne nous domine pas
faire en sorte qu'on doive pas tous
partir sur mars
des experts ont aussi une autre mission
qui est de s'assurer que l'ensemble des
gouvernements soient alignés sur un
certain nombre de normes des normes a co
créé parce qu'il ya des problèmes
déontologiques et des problèmes de
contextes culturels de situation c'est
tellement riche qu'il faut du débat il
faut aligner différentes visions la
juste un souci
le souci c'est l'agenda économique dans
certains acteurs je pense notamment aux
gouvernements de l'arabie saoudite qui
vient d'attribuer la nationalité aux
robots sofia un droit subjectif c'est à
dire qu'ils n'ont pas annoncé qu'ils
allaient attribuer des droits à tous les
robots sur terre mais à ce robot là en
particulier mais derrière ça il ya le
japon et à l'estonie qui sont également
en train d'évoquer d'attribuer les
droits très fort à des entités qui ne
sont même pas terminé
l'arrivée des robots physique n'est pas
pour tout de suite
par contre nous avons tous aujourd'hui
quelque chose dans nos mains avec lequel
nous interagissons au quotidien la
moyenne est de 2700 fois par jour nous
sommes devenus accros aux technologies
les siècles début si vous vous projetez
dans deux ou trois ans vous pouvez très
bien imaginer des mini robots virtuels
se mettre en place
qu'ils soient pas invisibles comme les
tchats vote actuels mais des des robots
qui correspondent à l'image que vous
aimeriez avoir d'un personnage ça peut
être un héros de bande dessinée
ça peut être un acteur d'une série
américaine
ça peut être un président est ce votre
robot virtuel mais quelque part sera
capable d'utiliser toutes les ressources
du téléphone en l'occurrence comprendre
le contexte si je suis sur le point de
rater mon avion de m'indiquer que je
risque réellement d'un raté mon avion le
téléphone est redoutable
ce qu'il est capable de nous observer
alors heureusement il n'ya pas
automatiquement un système de détection
de nos émotions
il ya des lois qui nous empêche de de
capturer ce qui sera compliqué avec les
robots c'est qu'ils seront constamment
en train de nous observer et là on a une
ligne rouge devant nous la ligne rouge
qui est jusqu'où on va t'on jusqu'où
permettons aux robots de nous analysé
denis quantifier de nous comprendre ce
problème là il est déjà aujourd'hui il
ya déjà des applications qui vous
appellent chaque jour jour après jour à
jouer le rôle de psychanalystes de
psychothérapeute
ils peuvent argumenter que c'est pour le
bien de l'ensemble de la société
vu qu'ils ont les technologies
exponentielle mais ça veut dire que les
questions se posent aujourd'hui il
ouch toutes les strates de la société
heureusement les experts sont nature
inclusive comprennent qu'on doit tous
pouvoir aussi s'exprimer sur ces
problématiques sur les différents
contextes et faire appel à notre
capacité de scénarisation non pas pour
prédire l'avenir mais pour l'anticiper
un minimum et ne pas subir les
conséquences de cette robotique des
sentiments sont quelque chose de magique
notre joie notre âme d'enfant et si
c'était pas là la solution pour éviter
nos erreurs j'aimerais faire appel à mon
imaginaire et vous projeter vers un faux
dans une situation particulière qu est
ce que tu peux venir là un temps là
ouais là par là
bah rapproche toi je présente comme le
robot du futur
comment ça va enfin peck et c'est toi ça
va super talent et biz de muriel
alexandre ah ouais voilà être se
réjouissent de voir la vidéo on verra
ouais ça tombe bien parce que là dans le
futur je fais un stage de clown en ce
moment non si la cei attend un succès
j'aimerais bien faire clown aussi moi je
vous permettre un truc ça je peux tu es
sûr oui mais bon on a un nez de clown
presque là j'ai pas du rouge
sérieusement oui un petit penses quoi de
mon talk about ça m'a beaucoup plu
moi j'adore voir indigente y fait mais
non mais plus sérieusement
en fait il faut quand même préciser une
chose essentielle c'est qu'il ya pas une
dizaine d' émotion universelle c'est que
chacun a son monde émotionnel très
personnel et très précis essayez voilà
c'est très riche et dans le futur vous
risquez bien de découvrir que en fait
chacun à sa façon à lui par exemple de
réagir à ma présence
exactement je crois que c'est et
neurosciences sont en train de prendre
conscience quelque chose qu'on sait
depuis longtemps c'est que nous sommes
tous uniques et nous avons tous des
émotions de manière unique n'ya pas les
gens juste content et les gens juste
fâché c'est beaucoup plus riche que ça
et est ce que ça te dit de jouer jouer à
quoi musique musique la musique parce
qu'en
tu sais jouer
non mais je veux bien prendre mon choix
brosse à dents enfin japon afin de
tester à huy
oh yeah
[Musique]
je continue comme ça je sais pas
tu passes un peu plus sa note 'aaa'
il apprend vite fait mon petit c'est
très bien joué il ya toutes les mélodies
de bach beethoven parce que rolling in
the way attendu
avis aux rapides
[Musique]
family viewing starving starring
facilement
[Musique]
oh
enfin pas 20 ans
[Musique]
enfin
à part en avant la fin
ouiais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]